[Applause]
hello tech community welcome back or
another live compensation it's a big one
today it's because they get you know
when we created this build back better
series I thought was how could we
address issues arising out of endemic
Calgary imagine building back from that
but the events of this past week the
horrific death of George Floyd in the
daily protests that have followed I mean
they provided a new urgency which we
have course simply have to address and
it can we build back better from this I
think before we can even start to answer
that question we just have to see to
understand that the immensity of this
moment that's that's right Chris right
now so many people in the United States
and Beyond are grappling with feelings
of anger and frustration deep deep
sadness and really helplessness no
matter who you are you have questions
about what to do now how to make things
better and as we've seen violence like
this unfold for many many years
what is the path forward so we're joined
today by a group of activists organizers
and leaders known for their crucial work
in social justice and civil rights we're
so grateful to have them here to engage
in a discussion about racial injustice
in America the unbearable acts of
violence that we've the acts of violence
against the black community that we
witnessed the dangers to a nation riven
by anger and fear and how on earth we
can move forward from this to something
better
so first each of our four guests will
share their thoughts on how we move
forward from this moment
then we'll engage as a group including
you the tech community and we'd like to
thank our partner the project management
institute their generous support has
helped me today anything's possible and
of course as Chris mentioned we want you
to take part in the conversation so
please share your questions using our
ask refreshing feature and Peter shared
their boss in the discussions right
thanks Whitney
okay that's living
that's guest dr. Phillip atiba
golf it's the founder and CEO of the
Center for policing equity they work
with police departments across America
including in Minneapolis to seek
measurable responses to racial bias bias
though I can scarcely imagine how to
stress in the last week must have been
view welcome and over T of your opening
comments thanks Chris yeah this week has
been a gut punch to anybody who felt
like we could be making progress in the
way that we put forward Public Safety
that empowers particularly vulnerable
communities we started working in
Minneapolis about five years ago at the
time it was like most major cities in
the United States a department that had
a long history of unaccounted for
violence from law enforcement targeting
the most vulnerable black communities
and we try to put into place a number of
things that we know work change the
culture so that the culture can be
accountable to the values of the
community and what we saw was small but
measurable progress we always knew with
small and measurable progress that your
one tragic incident from going back to
ground zero but the events of the last
week and a half haven't brought us back
to Ground Zero
they've torched Ground Zero and we've
dug a hole we have to dig ourselves out
of
what I hear from police chiefs who call
me from activists I talked to from folks
in in the communities that are literally
on fire right now I hear folks saying I
had one activist say to me that the pain
that he was feeling was too large to fit
into his body without thinking about I
said right back that's because it's too
large to fit into a lifetime what we're
seeing isn't just the response to one
gruesome cool public execution a
lynching it's not just the reaction to
three of them
Ahmad our burry Brianna Taylor and then
George Floyd what we're seeing is the
bill come due for the unpaid debts that
this country owes to its black residents
and it comes to usually every 20 to 30
years
it was Ferguson just six years ago but
about thirty years before that it was in
the streets of Los Angeles after the
verdict that exonerated the police that
beat Rodney King on video it was Newark
it was watts
it was Chicago it was Tulsa it was
Chicago again if we don't take a full
accounting of these debts that are owed
then we're gonna keep paying it part of
what I've been experiencing in the last
week and a half and what I've been
sharing with the people who do this work
we're serious about it is the the
acknowledgment the soul-crushing reality
that at some point when things stop
being on fire the cameras are going to
turn to something else
and the history that we have in this
country is not just a history of vicious
neglect and a targeted abuse of black
communities it's also one where we lose
our attention for it and what that means
for communities like in Baton Rouge
where those who still grieve Alton
sterling and in Baltimore for those who
are still grieving Freddie gray is that
there is not just a chance there's a
likelihood that we are a month or
two months out from this with no more to
show for it than what we had to show
after Michael Brown jr. and holding the
weight of that individually and
collectively is just too much it's just
too heavy a load for a person or a
people or a generation to hold up what
we're seeing is the unrepented sense the
unpaid debts and so the solution can't
just be that we fix policing it can't be
only incremental reform it can't be only
systems of accountability to catch cops
after they've killed somebody because
there's no such thing as justice for
George Florida
there's may be accountability there's
may be some relief from the people who
are still around who loved him for his
daughter who spoke out yesterday and
said my daddy changed the world
there won't be justice for a man who was
dead when he didn't have to be but we're
not gonna get to where we need to go
just by reforming police so in addition
to the work that CPE is known for with
the data we have been encouraging
departments and cities to take the money
that should be going to invest in
communities and take it from police
budgets bring it to the communities
people ask well what could it possibly
look like how could we imagine it and I
tell people there is a place where we do
this in the United States right now
we've all heard about it whispered some
of us have even been there some of us
lived there the place is called the
suburbs where we already have enough
resources to give to people so they
don't need the police for Public Safety
in the first place if someone has a
substance abuse issue they can go to a
clinic if somebody has a medical issue
they can go they've got insurance they
can go to a hospital if there's a
domestic dispute they have friends they
have support right you don't need to
enter a badge and a gun into it if we
hadn't disinvested from all the public
resources that were available in
communities that most needed those we
wouldn't need police in the first place
and many have been arguing
even more loudly recently that we don't
if we would just take the money that we
use to punish and instead invest it in
the promise in the genius of the
community that could be there so I don't
know all the ways we're gonna get there
I know it's gonna take everything and
it's gonna need the kind of systemic
change and the management tools that we
traditionally offer it's also gonna need
a quantum change in the way that we
think about public safety but mostly
this isn't just a policing problem this
is the unpaid debts that are owed to
black America the bill is coming due and
we need to start getting an accounting
together so we're not just paying off
the interest of the damn thing
maybe film Rashad Robinson is the
president of Color of Change the civil
rights organization that advocates for
racial justice for the black community
to date more than four million people
have signed the petition to arrest the
officers involved in the murder of
George Floyd and of course one was
arrested last week thank you so much for
being with us with Shai welcome thank
you
and thank you for having me it's a
opportunity that I'm taking today to
just tell you about how you can get
involved how you can take action because
right now strategic action is critical
for all of us to do the work to change
the rules that far too often keep the
systems in place that hold us back make
no mistake
the criminal justice system is not
broken it is operating exactly the way
it was designed at every single level
the criminal justice system is not about
providing justice but about ensuring
that certain people certain communities
are protected while other communities
are violated and so I want to talk a
little bit of today about Color of
Change about activism about the work
that's happening on the ground from
other organizations or all around the
country and the way that you can channel
this energy when we talk about that
Color of Change is how do you channel
presence into power and far too often we
mistake presence and visibility for
power presence retweets the stories of
the movement people feeling passionate
about change
um can sometimes make us feel like
change is inevitable but power is
actually the ability to change the rules
and right now everyday people are taking
action and what we're trying to channel
that energy into is a couple of things
first is a whole set of demands at the
federal level and at the local level on
this Phil described that policing on you
know operates on many different channels
and what we need to recognize is that
while there are a lot of things that can
happen at the federal level locally all
around the country there are decisions
that are being made in communities
around how policing is executed where
community needs to hold
per level of counter billing at the
state level we knew new laws so at Color
of Change we've built a whole platform
around a set of demands and are working
to build more energy of everyday people
to take action we're fighting for
justice for a Matar buri Brianna Taylor
and George Floyd we're also fighting for
justice for other folks whose names that
you haven't heard nina pop and others
whose stories of of injustice and the
relationship to the criminal justice
system represent all the ways in which
fighting right now is important over the
last couple of years we have worked to
build a movement to hold District
Attorney's accountable and to change the
role of district attorneys in our
country
and through the winning justice platform
at Color of Change WW winning justice
org what we have work to do is channel
the energy of everyday people to take
action so for folks who are watching
what's happening on TV seeing it on
their social media feeds and are
outraged about what's happening in
Georgia what's happening in Tennessee
what happening in Minnesota you yourself
probably most likely live in a place in
a community where you have a district
attorney that will not hold police
accountable that will not prosecute
police when they harm heard black folks
when they violate the laws you live in a
community where police are part of the
structure that is racking up mass
incarceration but many other aspects of
our system are racking up in karst mass
incarceration and district attorneys are
at the center of it you live in those
communities and you need to do something
about it
and so at winning justice daughter we've
created the only searchable national
database on the 2,400 prosecutors around
the country we're building local squads
and communities for folks to be able to
engage around on efforts to hold DA's
accountable we've worked with our
partners across the movement from our
friends and black lives matter to folks
who are do policy work to our friends at
local a cou chapters around the country
to build six demands six demands that
folks can get behind in terms of push
for reform and then we built public
education material but the only way that
we work to change the way the
prosecution happens in this country is
that if people get involved if people
raise their voice if people join us in
pushing for real change at the end of
the day I want people to recognize
though and Philip talked a little bit
about this is that people don't
experience issues they experience life
that the forces that hold us back or
deeply interrelated a racist criminal
justice system requires a racist media
culture survivor political inequality
follows economic inequality and they all
go hand in hand and so I also want us to
not take ourselves out of the equation
we likely work inside of corporations
that may post symbols for black lives
matter one day and then support
politicians that work to destroy black
lives matter the next day we oftentimes
are engaged in in practices inside of
our companies or in our daily life
supporting media properties and others
that are harming our communities are
telling stories recently we produced a
report a color of change with the norman
lear school at U at USC
it's called normalizing injustice and it
can be found that change Hollywood org
and normalizing injustice looks at the
22 crime procedurals those crime shows
on TV and looks at all of the ways in
which they sort of create a warped
perception about our view of justice may
they create sort of an incentive for the
type of policing we see on the country
and actually serve as a PR arm for law
enforcement we've been working in
writers rooms around the country to work
to push folks to tell better stories but
we need folks to be both active
listeners and we need folks in the
industry to push back and challenge
those not only the structures that lead
to that content coming on the air but
the proliferation across our Airways at
the end of the day we have an
opportunity in this moment to make
change inflection points are those
moments where we have an opportunity to
make huge leaps forward or the real
threat of falling backwards in our hands
is the ability to do some incredible
things about undoing so many of the in
justices that have stood in the way of
progress for far too long but every day
people must get involved we must
challenge channel that presence I'm into
power and we must build the type of
power that changes the rules racism in
so many ways is like water pouring over
a floor with holes in it every single in
every single way it will find the holes
and so for us we cannot simply accept
charitable solutions to structural
problems but we actually have to work
for structural change and so I want to
end by saying one thing about how we
talk about black people and how we talk
about black communities in this moment
because we have to say what we mean and
we have to build the narrative that gets
us to where we want to go so far too
often we talk about black communities as
vona but we talk about black people as
vulnerable but vulnerability is a
personal trait black communities have
been under attack black communities have
been exploited black communities have
been targeted and we need to say that so
we don't put the onus on fixing black
families and black communities but we
put the onus on fixing the structures
that have harmed us we will say things
like black people are less likely to get
loans from banks instead of saying that
banks are less likely to give loans to
black people this is our opportunity to
build the type of progress that makes
real change and at that center of the
story we need to show and elevate the
images not just of the pain that we are
facing
but of the joy the brilliance and the
creativity that black people have
brought to this country black people are
the protagonists of this story and we
need to make sure that as we work to
build a new tomorrow we ensure that the
heroes are at the center of the
liberation that we all do need thank you
thank you rashad dr. Bernie's King is
the CEO of the King Center in Atlanta
Georgia at the center
living memorial to her father dr. Martin
Luther King jr. is dedicated to
inspiring new generations to carry his
work forward in this moment when so many
are hurting how can we better approach
unity and collective healing dr. King
over to you my heart is a little heavy
right now because I was that six year
old I was five years old with my father
was assassinated and he did change the
world but the tragedy is that we didn't
hear what he was saying to us as a
prophet to his this nation and his words
are now reverberate reverberating back
to us change we all know is necessary
right now and yet it's not easy we know
that there has to be changes in policing
in this nation of ours but I want to
talk about America's choice at a greater
level the Prophet said to us we still
have a choice today
nonviolent coexistence or violent
correlation
when we have witnessed over the last
eight days has placed that choice before
us we have seen literally in the streets
of our nation people who have been
following the path of nonviolent protest
and people who have been hell-bent on
destruction those choices are now
looking at us and we have to make a
choice the history of this nation was
founded in violence in fact my father
said America is the greatest purveyor of
violence and the only way forward is if
we repent for being a nation built on
violence
and I'm not just talking about physical
violence I'm talking about systemic
violence I'm talking about policy
violence I'm talking about what he spoke
of or the triple evils of poverty racism
and militarism all violent
Albert Einstein said something to us he
said we cannot solve problems on the
same level of thinking in which they
were created and so if we are going to
move forward we are going to have to
deconstruct these systems of violence
that we have said America and we're
going to have to reconstruct on a
another foundation that foundation
happens to be love and non-violence
and so as we move forward we can correct
course if we make that choice that daddy
said non-violent coexistence and not
continue on the pathway a violent
correlation so what does that look like
that that looks like some deconstruction
work in order to get to the construction
we have to deconstruct our thinking
we've got to deconstruct the way in
which we see people and deconstruct the
way in which we operate practice and
engage and set policy and so I believe
that there's a lot of heart a ta RT work
to do
in the midst of all the HAR D hard work
to do because hard work is hard work one
of the things we have to do is we have
to ensure that everyone especially my
white brothers and sisters
have to engage in the heart work the
anti-racism work in our hearts no one is
exempt from this
especially in my white community we must
do that work in our hearts the
anti-racism work the second thing is
that I encourage people to look at the
non-violence training that leads the
King Center the King's in about org so
that we learn the foundation of
understanding our interrelatedness and
interconnectedness that we understand
our loyalties and commitments and our
policymaking can no longer be devoted to
one group of people but has to be
devoted to the greater good of all
people
and so I'm inviting people to even join
us on our online protest that's
happening every night at 7 o'clock p.m.
on the Kings and a Facebook page because
so many people have things that they
want to express and contribute to this
we all have to change and have to make a
choice it is a choice to change the
direction that we have been going we
need a revolution of values in this
country that's what my daddy said he
changed the world
he changed hearts
and now
what has happened over the last seven
eight years and through history we have
to change course and we all have to
participate in changing America with a
true revolution of values where people
are at the center and not profit when
morality is at the center and not our
military might America does have a
choice we can even choose to go down
continually that path of destruction or
we can choose non-violent coexistence
and as my mother said struggle is a
never-ending process freedom is never
really one you earn it and win it in
every generation every generation is
called to this freedom struggle you as a
person may want to exempt yourself but
every generation is called and so I
encourage corporations in America to
start doing anti-racism work within
corporate America I encourage every
industry to start doing anti-racism work
and pick up the banner of understanding
nonviolent change personally and from a
social change perspective we can do this
we can might make the right choice to
ultimately build the Beloved Community
thank you
Anthony Romero is the executive director
of the American Civil Liberties Union
has one of the nation's oldest social
justice organizations the ACLU has
advocated for racial equality and
showing deep support to the black
community in moments of crisis and in
moments like these black voices are
almost always the loudest and at times
the silence from our non black white
brothers non black brothers and sisters
conceal deafening how we can bring our
allies into the midst to better support
ending systemic violence and racism
against the black community as a
question top of mind for a lot of us
Anthony welcome to the show and thank
you so much for being with us thank you
thank you with me thank you Chris for
inviting me to join this type of
community I think community is really
important right now
but so many of us feeling the
trepidation the weariness the anger the
fear the frustration the terrorism the
experience in our communities this is a
time to huddle around a virtual campfire
with your Posse with your family with
your loved ones with your network not a
time to be isolated or alone and I think
for allies in this struggle those of us
who don't live this experience every day
and it's time for us to lean in and you
can't change the channel
you can't tune out you can't say this is
too hard it is not that hard for us to
listen and learn and it is the only way
we're gonna build build out of this by
hearing the voices of Rashad and Phil
and dr. King by hearing the voices of
our neighbors and loved ones by hearing
the voices on Twitter of people who we
don't know and so white communities and
allied organizations need to pay even
closer attention this is the test of
your character how willing are you
willing to lean in and to engage for me
I have these have been really hard
couple weeks I feel like this is really
a test
of whether or not we really believed in
the American experiment do we really
believe it do we really believe that out
of many one country with no unifying
language no need to find culture and
they'll either find religion can we
really become one people all equal
before the law all bound together with
belief from the world of law we really
believe that words we just think nice
saying to see on the back of a paper
dollar and for me this is a referendum
of the American experiment on whatever
we really believe and the future is in
our hand and this is not like other
crises I've been the head of the ACLU
for almost 20 years I feel like I've
seen it all this is different and this
is different because it is cumulative
like Phil and Rashad and dr. King told
us this is centuries of systemic
discrimination and the bill has come due
and it will continue to be due and we
will take unless we really do something
quite different I have been scratching
my head of the sou the last week we've
been at this for a hundred years my
organizations been working on this from
its inception in 1931 we were involved
with this report about lawlessness and
on in law enforcement that was our first
report have you got behind the 1931 we
opened up our first storefronts after
the riots in watts so that we can bring
legal services and lawyers the community
so they could demand justice from the
police departments you know we brought
Miranda you know the right to remain
silent
we brought Gideon the right to a
court-appointed attorney if you can't
afford one we fall Bloomberg on
stop-and-frisk it took in years and a
loss in front of our litigation to
finally apologize we've been at this for
a hundred years and for the communities
that have lived this for 400 years
and I've been scratching my head
thinking it ain't working we don't need
another pattern and practice lawsuits
we'd another training program on racial
bias or implicit bias and police
departments we don't need to find
another lawsuit of qualified immunity we
don't need to kind of bring another race
discrimination or gender discrimination
lawsuit to integrate the police
department yeah we've done that and we
will continue to do that for me where
I've come is that we need to defund the
budgets of these police departments the
only way we're going to take the power
back and the more I've read over the
last couple weeks about where this
country is the more unclear that that is
my North Star at the moment we will
continue to bring the litigation of
qualified immunity we will do the
efforts to hold unaccountable law
enforcement officials accountable we
will bring patterns and practice
lawsuits because the Justice Department
is not doing that so we will continue
doing all that good work but the real
thing is we're gonna go up to those
budgets when you look at the fact that
we spend a hundred million dollars on
policing more than incarceration that
the city of Minneapolis spent 30 percent
of their budgets on policing the City of
Oakland forty-one percent on policing
that when you have New York City Police
Department spends more money in policing
it does on housing and preservation
development community youth services
homelessness we're going after the money
and we're that's that's hardcore
advocacy bills drop and local
legislators to cut the funding to police
to stop these programs that give the
federal military surplus to police
department so they become like little
mini armies these almost like police
officers these are like standing armies
and the enemy are communities of color
so we need to take away their toys we
just cut their budgets we need to shrink
the police infrastructure so that we can
get police out of the quotidian lives of
people of color and conducive color
Vick we dismiss of police enforcement on
things that the police do not have a
role should not have a role to play
people do not should not lose their
lives over whether or not a cigarette
pack has a proper tax stamp or whether a
twenty dollar bill is for it or not
that's not worthy of spending our
dollars on police get them out of that
business let's focus on the most
important and the most serious of crimes
and that's it that's it even D police
our communities shrink those budgets
we're going to reinvest those monies in
local communities it will be like water
on stone campaigns and local legislators
local City Councils will have report
cards for people who talk out of both
sides of their mouth and say we believe
in police reform and yet they're still
going to vote for 30 or 40 percent to
the police we're going to put that right
to the public I think you just have to
stay at it because I think that's the
only way we can go get at this in a
different way because much of what we
tried to do is just simply not working
you know with that I I struggle with how
do you find the optimism in this moment
because you have to find the optimism
you have to find the way there can I
still think that even though in the face
of so many setbacks there's been changed
and too little too slow not enough we
took kind of rocket boost it but you
can't lose sight of the optimism and you
know I've been thinking about who are
the folks who inspire me dr. King's
father of course and the words of Rashad
and patrisse cullors and others have
inspired me but I found inspiration in
the words of a scholar I really don't
like very much Sam Huntington and I've
often criticized as being a conservative
a racist it's sometimes you can find
inspiration even in your enemy's work
and one of his books which I pulled off
this shelf I have it's just he writes
about how America is a disappointment
because it failed to live up to
desperation and he actually started
talking about it if America is a failure
because it doesn't live up to its ideals
but it's not a failure not a bunch of
lie the disappointment
and into disappointment also is the fact
that there's hope I'm paraphrasing it
but I think we have to go wrap all of
that together we think about the
disappointment and the hope and the
resolve to do better and you need to
listen and we min and I thank the tech
community I thank dr. King I think we
shot it Thank You Phil thank you Wow
thank you tell or for view that was
astonishing
I guess we're bringing everyone back now
to have a conversation among us to ask
some questions from our community I hope
you're entering those questions so I
don't know whether we can bring back
I'll guess onto the screen at this point
welcome back I guess I'll start let me
start with a question to you dr. King I
was so inspired by what you said your
father of course also deeply understood
the anger that leads to protests I think
he he said that protests the language of
the unheard and I'm wondering what what
you would say to someone right now who
is angered beyond measure by what's
happened and also sees this could be the
moment you know like that they someone
who believes the system is so
fundamentally broken that our best
choice is to tear it down that that is
actually that this may be a one once in
a generational moment to do that and and
so to actually believe that protests
including violent protests actually is
the way right now what would you say to
someone who felt that first I just
wanted to make just the slight
correction he said riots of the language
of the unheard is the point even more
powerfully yeah yes
protest we must and we must continue to
always protest to keep the issues and
the awareness before people but you know
when a person is angry sometimes it's
hard to reach them I've been on that
journey I was at a stage of my life
where I was so angry I wanted
to destroy and I'm the daughter of
Martin Luther King jr. and grew up in a
household of love and non-violence and
forgiveness
and I had to go through that journey I
was surrounded by the right kind of
influences fortunately because that
would have been a sad story but I think
it's it's really allowing ourselves to
hear the anger and allowing the space
for the anger but also trying to help
young people we channel that that energy
and and we've got to start ensuring that
we connect them to some of the work that
has been and now is elevated to another
place color change the work that you're
doing the ACLU the work that they're
doing because sometimes there's this
disconnection that intensifies the
emotion and makes you feel helpless but
if you can channel that anger connect it
with action that is is toward creating
the social and economic change then it
begins to build you up and then you can
begin to become more constructive with
the anger some questions that are coming
in from our community but before we do
that you all shirts as powerful and evil
statements right now and many of you
touched on the fact this is not the
first time that we're experiencing this
the murder of George Floyd Ahmad are
very bianna Taylor but this is one of
these are three of many many instances
just like this and I'd love to hear you
all address what has sort of brought us
to this boiling point what has
contributed to this moment we were now
experiencing things as Anthony as you
said feels so much worse than than other
other moments
and that's it anyone who feels
uncomfortable to sort of take that
question I wanted to say something that
speak to that I think I think we've
always been at that moment but this
moment is different because of the void
and leadership there's no real moral
voice in our country and the person who
sits in the office of the presidency is
not you know leading in the right way
and so it is and it's kind of you know
that kind of has given license to
certain things and so now it's you know
he's lit the fires the thing the thing
I'll add here is that you know I think a
couple of things for the last couple of
months we have been both seeing and
experiencing all of the ways that this
country's decisions of underinvestment
of targeting black communities has been
killing black people through Kovach and
while we've been in our homes we have
also been watching how the media has
blamed us as we have been the essential
workers in so many places and trying to
ensure that this country keeps going
we've watched white men with guns show
up to capitals with demanding basically
black and brown people go back to work
and then we see this eight-minute video
with the police officer with his knee on
someone's neck after seeing that video
of Ahmad our burry and hearing the story
of Rihanna Taylor and we see him looking
in the camera basically knowing that
America was not going to punish him and
what I think is that it's just enough is
enough that people didn't feel that that
they had a channel for that outraging
and because people had been inside and
because people had been experiencing all
the ways in which the structures um had
also been colluding to kill us that what
we're seeing is a alignment of all of
those things where people are making
demands at
much bigger and much bolder than before
and we recognize that while we don't
have leadership at the federal level we
also have to recognize that I'm no
political party can say that they have
been 100 for neither political party can
say they have been 100 percent on the
right side of all these issues and so
people are mobilizing they are fighting
back and like never before and in some
ways people are unwilling to accept
answers like Jessica vote or just
participate in the process because we
recognize that black people have been
voting black people have been part of
voting and part of ensuring that and so
that I think is why this moment feels so
much different combined with for the
last seven years since Trayvon we have
seen the growth of a new movement of
activists and leaders all around the
country who are also in a very different
place to be able to move the needle on
so much of what's possible we have a
question from Genesis be if we can get
it up here
here in Mississippi the police is
synonymous with the Klan historically
how do we how do we purge law
enforcement of white supremacist
so I guess that that's partially to me
being the psychologist of bias I'll say
that just yesterday we had an officer in
Denver who posted on social media
himself and two other officers saying
let's go start a riot
he was fired that day I worry about all
the officers that the FBI has now for
almost half a decade been warning us our
being in law enforcement and unions
being infiltrated by white supremacists
and all the officers that have social
media accounts but they're private you
know the original Institute has put some
things forward we're not talking
seriously about the domestic terrorism
threat that white supremacy represents
so the first thing we got to do is we
got to take it seriously we have to
actually say out loud and I can't
believe that on a day like today a week
like the week this week I have to say
out loud white supremacy is alive and
well and a driving force of American
politics this shouldn't be controversial
I shouldn't be looking too forward to
getting hate mail in my inbox for it but
that's the reality so the first thing
first part of solving a problem is
acknowledging it exists but the second
thing is we need to arm municipalities
that's law enforcement beef and more so
communities with the ability to take
action when someone violates their
values right now I think about the case
in Philadelphia where Charles Ramsey
when he was chief there his Commissioner
there fired six officers right concerns
about racial bias and concerns about
police brutality those six officers were
back on the same job inside of three
months we now have a law enforcement
system that says you can lose your job
in one jurisdiction and get the same job
as law enforcement in another
jurisdiction and without without those
national registry and the capacity for
law enforcement to make different
decisions we're going to have this exact
problem not just in Mississippi but in
Minneapolis and Louisville in New York
and LA so how much of the of the problem
stems from the fact that police unions
have a huge amount of power to protect
and sometimes
reinstate so-called bad apple offices
yes oh I'm getting this question a lot
and police unions are one of the most
powerful labor forces in the United
States and are unique within the labor
movement right so it's police unions and
teachers unions are the two largest and
could not be two different sets of
groups of photos um when I talk to Union
leadership that's the leadership that
wants to talk to dr. blackenstein right
when I talk to Union leadership what
they say is no one hates a bad officer
more than a good officer but the union
contracts the new negotiations don't
look like that's true what they look
like is anybody gets in trouble and the
unions only jobs to make sure whatever
officer is in trouble gets to maintain
their job the perverse incentive here is
that when people run for union
leadership no one can run saying these
people shouldn't be in the Union it's
very hard to do that what you can run on
and say this person didn't protect you
enough right I'll protect you even more
of the bigots I'll protect even them so
we have this perverse incentive where
union leadership ends up not really
representing the values even of the rest
of the union members but they have
massive outsize negotiating power so yes
engaging with an appropriate right
sizing of labor protections for folks
whose jobs are difficult but who should
not be protected from the basic values
of human rights human dignity and public
safety it's got to be part of the
process I mean when when unions are
negotiating a two-year ban on keeping of
records so that there's no ability even
to trace what's happening in the state
of California historically in terms of
police misconduct that's not in the
interest of Public Safety public
legitimacy for our democracy yeah the
thing I would add Chris is that I think
the labor union piece is a critically
important one to think through because I
think like Phil savage they are a key
part of the puzzle that's gonna have to
solve for and you know it's frustrating
when you look at a place in Minneapolis
I feel most better than I but when Mayor
Jacob Frye the one who's on TV all the
time saying oh you know many of the
right things and you want to elected
official to say it sound like this when
he banned his police that
Hartman from attending the warrior
training that was being offered it was
the Minneapolis Police Federation local
union who defied him and sent their
police to the training and so we need to
really be clear that we have the police
forces under civilian control I know
this sounds Elementary I feel like I'm
talking about a Latin American kind of
cause totalitarian context but it kind
of exert civilian control of our police
in a way that we have yet not been able
to think through and a key part that is
the labor unions of the police and there
are moments when you can find common
ground when we brought one of our koban
related lawsuits to deal with the
outbreak of the pandemic in a Maryland
Jail we worked really hard I worked the
phones with the head of police unions we
got one of the local unions to serve as
plaintiff in our lawsuit because we
understood that the incarcerated folks
who are being denied access to mass and
social distancing and the conditions and
lack of testing a lack of PPE but the
people who also be the harm's way we're
going to be the guards as well and they
were going to be the kind of vectors
communicating the the disease out into
the community so if you can find ways of
kind of bringing that relationship but
make no mistake when you go after their
budgets and you start taking away their
kind of their munitions and their and
their seat at the budgeting table well
are you gonna have a battle on your
hands right and we have to think about
also as we drink the budgets for police
how do we when we deploy people in the
police departments to other meaningful
jobs right because you can't just throw
them out on the street and say you're on
your own you're homeless good luck to
you that's not it that's not a way to
deal with Redemption so we have to
really think about all these pieces in a
much more cohesive way Whitney we have
another question here from the audience
yeah from Paul Rucker at the end of
summer of 1919 Boston was followed by
the Tulsa Race Massacre the Johnson
agreed anti-immigration accent
24 and also the rise of the KKK is there
a possibility that white supremacy will
get stronger if you don't seize this
opportunity
Rashaad I think this may be something
they'll be great to hear in their
perspective on working so deeply in
activism I'm having a little trouble
hearing okay no it's okay can you can
you read the question on the screen
Russia oh oh I heard that I heard yes
yes I think I might just be my mic is
having some issues here but uh yes he
just is there a possibility that white
supremacy yes absolutely yes um you know
well like like to be clear right if we
don't have the right diagnosis of white
supremacy if we think of white supremacy
as just hoods if we think of white
supremacy as is just folks who are
operating you know with you know in some
of these sort of underground networks
that have grown if we're just thinking
about white supremacy and white
nationalism as people who marks with
tiki torches in Charlottesville then we
will really mistake all the ways in
which our systems and structures have
white supremacy embedded and allow for
some something like a Tulsa race
Massacre to happen something like
anti-immigration happened but on a day
to day basis allow for the targeting of
black communities through predatory
practices by banks the targeting of
practices like bail a whole set of
systems that can be produced day in and
day out we live in a country where the
rules are far too often designed in ways
that that creates a caste system that
creates a different standard for some
over others and so when I talked about
the inflection point right of this
moment where something could really go
forward or something could turn
backwards um we are seeing
right now with this current president
and as we look at what could potentially
happening with the next election we have
to be very we have to be very clear that
Donald Trump doesn't just operate on his
own he's enabled by big corporations who
benefit from him being in office and so
continue to turn a blind eye to all the
things that he does they may post black
lives matter but they show up to the
White House and engage with Donald Trump
and then we have a whole set of
politicians that may sometimes say that
he said something that was wrong but
then allow for but support his platform
in other ways um you know trucco
conspiracy in the effort to dismantle
white supremacy and white nationalism is
not a thing that people can do on
vacation it is a 365 day project of us
constantly working to dismantle all of
the structures that have been put in
harm's way the thing I the final thing I
will just add about because someone
mentioned about police unions and I want
to just add that part of the one of the
problems with police unions and and many
of us have been in this position I think
is that I have shown up to the table
with police unions on many occasions I
remember going to the White House and
during the last administration and being
around a table as we were talking about
policing and police reform and having
members of the Fraternal Order of Police
leadership say things like all of this
talk of racial profiling is new to us it
is one thing for folks to not agree with
you on the policy reforms necessary it
is another thing for people to say that
our demands are too aspirational it's
another thing to be gas-lit and told the
problem doesn't actually exist at all
and that is what we are dealing with and
so we have to actually change the way
that people see these institutions
politicians who say that they are on the
side of justice and reform can no longer
take money from police only unions and
Fraternal Order of Police
we actually have to create a new
standard a new litmus test of what does
it mean to actually be with us you can't
just sing our songs use our hashtags and
marching our marches if you are on the
other end
supporting the structures that put us in
harm's way that literally kill us and
this is the opportunity for white allies
to actually stand up in new ways to be
the to be the type of out to do the type
of ally ship in the type of work that
truly dismantle structures not just
provide charity and I got to add to that
we're at so Paul thank you for the
question but we're in a moment where
people a lot of people are looking at
what's happening on the street as if as
if a week and a half ago we weren't in
the midst of a global pandemic as the
greatest news story the biggest news
story going on one of the things I'm
most worried about and have been worried
about since the very beginning when I've
been talking to our Chiefs about who we
work with is say you must be out of the
social distancing policing get the game
you can't be the ones doing that and the
reason is this we're in a moment we're
creating scapegoats and enemies and
others is incredibly politically
advantageous for at least one side and
there is a deliberate efforts to do
exactly that and we've seen that that
black communities are two and three and
four times more likely to contract this
virus which feels like the manifestation
of racial discrimination because it is
but very soon that's going to look like
black people made bad choices and they
need to stay away from us and when that
happens that's when law enforcement gets
used to regulate where black movement
can be we used to call it sundown towns
I don't know what we're gonna call it
when it's around kovat but it's coming
I'm already seeing that on communities
like next-door and on Facebook groups of
people who don't think of themselves as
white supremacists
but just what the disease when the
disease has a black and brown phase so
we're not only dealing with a moment of
of generational tension between black
communities and law enforcement we're
dealing with a moment when people are
looking for scapegoats and black
people's vulnerability has always been
our greatest casting note for being cast
as scapegoats so for folks who are
worried about this this is not
inevitably a moment for change and
reform and enlightenment and America's
best values because historically these
have been precisely the moment when
regression back to white supremacy
reign supreme so let's not just look at
everybody's signal I don't want to just
see black black and white cops on their
knees I want to see the policies I want
to see the things that will prevent this
kind of thing from moving to the next
stage mm-hmm Rashaad I I want to respect
that then you've got a hard stop at at
one and so I just want to thank you for
your participation in this if you if
you've got a couple of final words you
want to share that would be great and
then if it's okay for the other three I
just I think there's just a couple other
questions I'd love to to put and
continue this conversation for just a
moment longer if first of all reset it
because the thing the thing I want to
say is that now is the time for action
and I want to invite people in to join
us at Color of Change to make it to make
justice real and in so many ways you can
visit us at Color of Change you can take
action 5 10 15 years from now we will be
dealing with the impacts in the of what
we did or didn't do in this moment how
we stood up and how and how hard we were
willing to fight and as the other
speakers have said now is not the time
for a reform around the edges now is
time for dismantling the policies and
practices that have hold us back and
championing solutions and new rules that
will move us forward and so we hope that
you will do something whether it's with
us or whether it's with local
organizations in your community or other
groups around the country but this is an
opportunity to make change and I believe
that we can make justice real if we find
the passion and the in the energy to
work together to achieve it so thank you
all for having me and I hope and I hope
that we have an opportunity to build not
just online but offline on in the months
to come thanks so much
Rashad we're just gonna ask this last
question of your distance from David
Fenton how can the movement unite around
a clear simple platform of policies to
enshrine in legislation like making all
complaints against cops public burning
or chokeholds ensuring independent
review boards etc
I think that was to go to you dr. King
okay you know this may sound simplistic
but it it's it's a Nike thing I think we
have to just do it we have to see our
work is interconnected
I think there's been efforts towards
people working in that vein but we have
to intensify that and in doing it one of
the things that my father said and I
know people sometimes get tired of
hearing me say my father said but I just
think I wish should I say we had really
listened to him because we wouldn't be
on this platform right now having this
kind of conversation but he left
something with a sort of a blueprint and
where do we go from here chaos of
community his book and he said going
forward the nettlesome task is to
organize our strength into compelling
power and that is so key because often
times we organize merely around passion
but people have certain areas of
strength and and talent and giftedness
and we've got to figure out how to build
our coalition's based on these strengths
you know people do different things well
and so in order to unite in an effective
way that they might not elude the demand
that we're making I think that's what's
going to have to happen people have to
do their own personal assessment within
their organization that I call it a SWOT
analysis and then that's what analysis
has to happen across organizations so
that we can make sure that we're moving
in the united manner off of the
strengths that each organization brings
so that we can maximize the the impact
of the effectiveness to to do things
like this in terms of getting the
legislation in place that is needed in
this hour
thanks so much just to
quick closing words from you Anthony and
then from you Phil Anthony you know I
would just say that what gives me hope
are the young hook you have to believe
that among this group this group of
young uns seeing what they're seeing
living with this president with these
instincts seeing the continued
indifference that mainstream communities
have given to issues of racial justice
or economic justice
you gotta believe that what comes out of
this kind of very hot fire is something
even more powerful and strong than we've
ever seen before and if that's what gets
me through the hard days that were now
experiencing this thinking there is
another dr. King among the young uns dr.
King and I have to believe that what
they're seeing and what they're
witnessing and their righteous
indignation and frustration and their
anger is going to be miraculously a
beautiful blossoming of a new
opportunity of a new change face this
generation will take us there I have to
believe that our generations failed them
miserably so I'm just looking forward to
this the new one
Thank You Anthony so it's it does it
really has been a privilege to be on
with you all to David's question let me
say that a number of civil rights
organizations I believe the ACLU among
them a CBE number of a center for
policing equity and hundreds more have
signed on to principles for a
legislation that would include eight
pillars it's been led by the Leadership
Conference for civil and human rights
and includes a federal ban on choke
holds it includes a national registry
for officers who've engaged in
misconduct I also think that it's
important at this moment to get we've
got law enforcement Chiefs of major
cities willing to say if we emerge from
this moment and our profession hasn't
changed and we have failed again so it's
a critical time to get behind I would I
would direct you to the LCC hrs website
for the eight pillars but I won't
to the mall right now and to start
calling your local law enforcement say
yes on that you should be signing on
they should be going public with letters
that do all of that but I'll also say
this for a path forward and the
principles I'll end where we where I
started which is that this is bigger
than policing these are the unpaid debts
owed to black communities for stolen
labor owned 202 native communities for
stolen land for stolen culture for years
taken away and from lives lost in it
this is bigger than policing if we don't
understand the size of it then there's
no solution that's really truly poor
proportional to the moment but in this
moment when we're seeing trillions of
dollars in bailouts mostly for
corporations it is absolutely a time
when we can do things that normally
people could pretend that's too much
it's too bad we can't we have literally
all the money in the world that can be
spent and directed towards making us a
society we pretend to be before moments
like this happen so the thing that gives
me hope is that the lies have to be
obvious now the lies have to be that was
a reasonable use of force the lie has to
be we don't have the money the lie has
to be that's too hard it's too big of a
challenge this stuff feels impossible
every day except today because the
alternative is we lose everything
everything is at stake our democracy is
at stake the people we choose to be we
claim to be that's at stake and in the
face of that I think we can do
impossible things I think we can be
mighty so my hope for all of us is first
that we wake up tomorrow with more peace
in the evening than war and that we hold
on to what's possible from this moment
at the same time that we hold on to the
size of the task in front of us I don't
want to come out with half measures out
of this I don't want to come out with
radicalized youth and in different age I
don't know what the contract that
radicalized use and indifferent people
who are old like me I want to come out
with a unify
country that understands that the cost
that we owe are big and our pockets are
deep enough to match it well thank you
to each of you for eloquence really so
powerful and this conversation obviously
continues I know that there's many
people are saying you'll have other
questions this I think from Ted's point
of view is just the start of the
conversation but if to the extent that
our job is to amplify voices that matter
we couldn't be prouder to be amplifying
further your extraordinary voices so
thank you for being part of this today